[Musique]
alors voici matteo mois lou anne k et
maël messone caillis sept personnages
qui sont les héros d'une bande dessinée
et les avatars de ces sept jeunes
illustrateurs en herbe ce groupe
d'enfants accompagnés par la maison
départementale de sainte-marie réalise
une bande dessinée un projet visant à
développer la création l'estiment de soi
et les formes d'expression culturelle
afin de créer un livre qui s'appelle à
sancerre chaos raconte quoi l'écologie
la sarre à contes des les enfants débit
qui sont en train de se chamailler et
après un moment donné une sorcière ce
sens cet assaut mais moi ce que je veux
dire c'est que j'aime bien fallu lui
lorsqu on est ensemble et je veux que ça
sera super il faudra une année de
travail pour l'écriture et la
réalisation de ces esquisses pour
raconter leur histoire
un projet qui se dessine après la mise
en place d'un atelier d'expression
autour des émotions
ce groupe s'est alors constituée et
soutenus par leurs parents ces jeunes
créateurs s'initie au neuvième art celui
de la bande dessinée ce projet s'inscrit
aussi dans la globalité de de notre de
notre souhait nous entendrions sociaux
de développer justement l'intérêt pour
la culture et de faciliter l'accès aux
temps forts de la culture à la réunion
de façon générale pour des publics qui
sont en sont encore sont le plus souvent
éloignés
accompagné par l'artiste plasticien
clémence triano le corps du livre se met
en place un projet qui se réalise
également en partenariat avec la
bibliothèque départementale de la
réunion avec pour vocation d'ouvrir la
culture au plus grand nombre
dans un premier temps ils viennent avec
leurs éducateurs et par la suite ils
sont venus avec leur famille donc là
pour nous tout est gagné
ils sont venus ce sont eux les messagers
qui ont emmené leurs parents dans ce
lieu de culture qui ils n'ont pas
l'habitude forcément de fréquenter parce
qu'ils sont pas de la commune il habite
à sainte marie donc revenir avec ses
parents ses frères et soeurs découvrir
et c'est eux qui présentent la
bibliothèque donc nous pour la
bibliothèque on est très contentes ce
partenariat la restitution de ce travail
se fera pour le mois d'octobre
les enfants se feront une joie de vous
raconter leur histoire
[Musique]